House of the Dragon Episode 8 is set six years
after the previous episode.
So there are now new actors playing Rhaenyra’s
kids Jace Luke and Joff, and Daemon’s kids
Baela and Rhaena, and Alicent’s kids Aegon,
Helaena and Aemond.
Alicent’s family have been ruling in King’s
Landing, while Rhaenyra and her family have
been living on Dragonstone, and Rhaenys and
Baela are on Driftmark.
But now, as King Viserys and Lord Corlys both
seem near death, their families come together
and try to make peace before it’s too late.
So what happens and what does it mean?
This video has no spoilers for Hot D past
episode 8.
Rhaenys Targaryen has been ruling Driftmark,
the Velaryon island.
Because her husband Lord Corlys Velaryon has
been at war on the Stepstones, fighting the
Triarchy.
Daemon killed the Triarchy’s leader the
Crabfeeder years ago, but this war continues.
And now Corlys is wounded, and it seems he
might die.
In the books, Corlys isn’t wounded, he just
gets sick because he’s old – Corlys is
now seventy-six years old in the books.
So Corlys’ brother Vaemond asks who will
be the next Lord of Driftmark if Corlys dies.
Corlys wants Lucerys Velaryon to inherit Driftmark,
cause Luke is supposedly the son of Laenor
Velaryon.
But Vaemond says that since Luke is actually
Harwin Strong’s bastard, Vaemond should
get Driftmark.
While Rhaenys previously said that she wants
her granddaughter Baela to inherit Driftmark.
So this begins a power struggle between Luke,
Vaemond and Baela to control the second most
powerful house in Westeros, House Velaryon.
On Dragonstone, Daemon and Rhaenyra now have
two sons named Aegon and Viserys.
Daemon has settled into married life, and
just as Viserys’ dad hobby was his model
city, Daemon’s hobby is collecting dragon
eggs.
Daemon climbs around the Dragonmont, a volcanic
mountain on Dragonstone, and he finds some
dragon eggs laid by Rhaenyra’s dragon Syrax.
The eggs are laid in a sack that’s hard
on the outside and warm on the inside, it
looks like the eggs in the movie Alien, and
apparently this is how dragon eggs incubate
in the wild.
Daemon takes the eggs to put in a “warming
chamber”, maybe he’ll give them to his
new sons.
Dragons are weapons, and Daemon is stockpiling
eggs for future conflict – like an apocalypse
prepper filling a bunker with fire-breathing
nukes.
Daemon’s Dragonkeepers have blood and burns
on their faces – looks like wrangling dragons
is a dangerous job.
Rhaenyra’s eldest son Jace practices speaking
Valyrian.
He says that Aegon the Conqueror ordered for
some trees to be felled.
Cause when Aegon landed on Westeros he cleared
away forest to build what eventually became
the city of King’s Landing.
He didn’t cut down every tree though – there’s
still that weirwood tree in the Red Keep,
sacred to the old gods.
Jace is the heir to the Throne after Rhaenyra,
so he studies hard, and takes his responsibilities
seriously.
Unlike Alicent’s eldest son Aegon, who takes
nothing seriously except for masturbation.
We see the Painted Table, a map of Westeros
that Aegon made before his Conquest.
Stannis and Daenerys use this same table later
in Game of Thrones.
Rhaenyra and Daemon learn that Vaemond wants
to take Driftmark instead of Luke.
If Luke is disinherited for being a bastard,
that could weaken Jace and Rhaenyra’s claims
to the Throne.
And if Luke doesn’t get Driftmark, their
family won’t get the Velaryons’ wealth
and powerful ships.
So Rhaenyra and her family go back to King’s
Landing to defend their power.
Rhaenyra doesn’t get a big official welcome
to the Keep – Otto specifically keeps it
low-key to undermine Rhaenyra, and make her
seem less important.
Kinda like Viserys’ welcome to Driftmark
previously.
Rhaenyra is greeted only by Lord Allun Caswell
– we saw him previously congratulating Rhaenyra
after childbirth.
House Caswell have a centaur for a sigil and
they rule Bitterbridge in the Reach.
Rhaenyra and Daemon find that the Red Keep
has changed while they were gone.
Alicent and Otto have taken down Targaryen
heraldry, and covered up those dragon orgy
murals, and replaced them with symbols of
the Faith of the Seven.
The showrunners say that Alicent turns to
religion to redeem herself after she attacked
Rhaenyra last episode.
But this is also a political move.
Cause the Faith is closely tied to the power
of House Hightower – the Faith is based
in the Hightower city of Oldtown.
These religious symbols may imply disapproval
of Rhaenyra’s incestuous marriage with Daemon,
and of her bastard children.
The removal of Targaryen imagery shows that
the Targaryens aren’t in charge here – Otto
and Alicent Hightower control the Throne.
Rhaenyra and Daemon go visit Viserys, and
see that Viserys’ model city is now covered
in cobwebs, there’s even a rat on it.
Viserys is so sick that he’s no longer working
on his passion project.
And the neglected dirty city suggests that
Viserys’ kingdom is corrupt, his realm is
disordered.
The smoke amidst the city evokes the smoking
ruin of Valyria after its downfall.
Viserys’ sickness is something like leprosy.
He’s in constant pain, body parts are falling
off, and part of his face is now gone.
Daemon has always looked to Viserys for approval
and love, so he’s so devastated to see his
brother dying that Daemon can hardly look
at Viserys.
Rhaenyra shows Viserys his new grandsons – Aegon
and Viserys.
Viserys is named after King Viserys.
And Aegon is named after Aegon the Conqueror.
Of course, Alicent already has a son named
Aegon.
The books say that Rhaenyra named her kid
Aegon the same name to insult Alicent.
And it also shows Rhaenyra’s political ambitions
– naming her kids after King Viserys and
King Aegon suggests that Rhaenyra’s children
are the true royal bloodline.
Unlike Jace, Luke and Joff, who are obviously
Harwin’s bastards because of their dark
hair, Aegon and Viserys have Targaryen blonde
hair – they look like kings.
And Rhaenyra is now pregnant again with her
sixth child.
Viserys is happy to meet his new grandkids,
though the grandkids are less happy to meet
him.
When Viserys is overwhelmed with pain, he
drinks milk of the poppy, which is basically
opium, a painkiller.
So Viserys is drugged out of his mind half
the time, and lets Alicent and Otto run the
kingdom for him.
So Rhaenyra and Daemon think Viserys will
be no help with the Driftmark succession issue.
Alicent and Otto run a small council meeting,
dealing with such thrilling issues as the
taxation of wool.
Viserys once said that Daemon could never
be king because he’d find the actual work
of government to be boring.
If he had to sit at a table every day putting
up with all this bullshit, Daemon would go
mad.
But Alicent and Otto have the patience, and
are doing the work.
Though they’re also scheming for their own
ambitions.
Alicent speaks with a Kingsguard called Erryk
Cargyll.
Erryk has a twin brother called Arryk who’s
also a Kingsguard, and Alicent can’t tell
Erryk and Arryk apart.
Also on the Kingsguard is Commander Harrold
Westerling, Criston Cole, Steffon Darklyn,
and two others we haven’t met yet.
Alicent learns that her son Prince Aegon raped
a servant called Dyana.
Dyana is traumatised, and terrified that she’ll
be punished.
In this world, we see many women punished
or killed for having sex with the wrong person,
even if they didn’t choose to.
Some women are labelled whores or sinners.
A noble girl who has sex outside wedlock might
be hastily married someplace, or sent away
to be a sister of the faith.
But lowborn girls like Dyana may be considered
permanently tarnished, labelled as whores
or sinners.
Alicent comforts Dyana.
Maybe she relates to Dyana, because Alicent
experienced Viserys having sex with her when
she didn’t want to.
But Alicent also subtly threatens Dyana, and
pays her so that she won’t tell anyone that
Aegon raped her.
Alicent presents her family as the religious
and virtuous royals, so she doesn’t want
rumours of Aegon’s crimes shaming her family.
And she doesn’t want rumours of potential
royal bastards who might become rival claimants
for the Throne.
So on one level, Alicent supports Dyana, but
at the same time Alicent silences Dyana and
protects Aegon’s reputation.
Rhaenyra previously said that Alicent wears
a “cloak” of “righteousness” – like,
her image as a righteous virtuous woman is
a fake disguise to hide her family’s corruption.
Alicent participates in enforcing the same
patriarchal system that had trapped her.
Alicent gives Dyana moon tea to prevent pregnancy,
like when Rhaenyra had moon tea.
Mellos said that moon tea can be “unpleasant”
if brewed improperly.
In the books, Lysa Tully almost dies from
drinking moon tea.
So hopefully Dyana’s okay.
Alicent confronts Aegon, and shouts at him
for raping Dyana.
Alicent seems more concerned about the political
consequences of the rape than about its immorality.
Alicent slaps Aegon, as she did last episode.
Alicent’s parenting of Aegon involves a
lot of shouting and hitting, and this has
not made Aegon a better person.
Alicent is disgusted by him, and tells Aegon
“You're no son of mine”.
Tywin says the same thing to Tyrion in Game
of Thrones.
And we see in Tyrion the pain that is caused
by a parent’s rejection.
Aegon doesn’t get much love from his father
Viserys either.
Maybe Aegon’s feelings of rejection fuel
his cruel behaviour, expressing his pain by
hurting others.
Kinda like Tyrion in the later books.
Alicent hugs Helaena, who is Aegon’s sister
and wife.
Aegon and Helaena now have two young children
who we haven’t seen yet.
And Alicent feels terrible for Helaena being
married to this useless cheating rapist.
Even though the Hightowers’ political ambitions
are probably why Aegon and Helaena got married
in the first place.
Alicent faces Rhaenyra and Daemon after long
years apart.
We see the scar on Rhaenyra’s arm where
Alicent slashed her last episode.
And two sides remain prickly and passive aggressive
with each other.
Rhaenyra says Alicent and Otto are deliberately
keeping Viserys weak and drugged so that they
can rule in Viserys’ name.
But Alicent argues that Viserys needs the
drugs for his pain, and that the Hightowers
are doing the right thing.
Jace and Luke visit the training yard.
They remember one time when Luke tried to
use Criston’s morningstar, and almost hit
himself in the head.
Criston’s actor says that he was more worried
about hitting himself in the balls, which
was quote “not cool” and “not rock and
roll”.
Luke is uncomfortable being here to claim
Driftmark, knowing that he’s not Laenor
Velaryon’s son, that he looks like his real
father Harwin.
This young man is forced to lie about his
identity for the sake of his parents’ politics.
Jace supports his brother by saying it doesn’t
matter what other people think.
Which sounds nice, but.. it’s really not
true.
Politics is all about what people think.
And if no one believes in Luke’s legitimacy,
he won’t survive as a ruler.
We see Aemond Targaryen training with Criston
Cole.
The books say that with Criston’s training,
Aemond became a “proficient and dangerous
swordsman”, despite the loss of his eye.
Criston says Aemond will win tournaments with
his skill.
But Aemond says he doesn’t care about tourneys.
Aemond only cares about real fights, real
killing.
Then he looks at Jace and Luke.
Luke cut out Aemond’s eye last episode,
and Aemond wants revenge.
Vaemond Velaryon marches in surrounded by
Velaryon and Hightower heraldry.
Vaemond knows that in politics “what other
people think” is everything.
So he presents himself as the true Velaryon
heir, with House Hightower’s support.
Otto and Alicent meet with Vaemond, and Otto
says there may be war soon.
He means that the Triarchy on the Stepstones
could become a threat to Westeros, but he
also thinks there could be war between Rhaenyra
and Aegon for the Throne.
Which is largely Otto’s fault for pushing
Aegon as heir.
To prepare for war, the Hightowers want the
support of House Velaryon, with their money
and ships.
Vaemond says that if they help him inherit
Driftmark, Vaemond will support the Hightowers.
Once they disinherit Luke, Otto hopes to disinherit
Jace and Rhaenyra, and to put his grandson
Aegon on the Throne.
But Alicent has doubts.
She’s not sure if she wants to go against
Corlys and Viserys’ wishes.
And does she really want her terrible son
Aegon to be king?
While the Hightowers make an alliance with
Vaemond, Rhaenyra tries to ally with Rhaenys.
Rhaenys is happy to see her granddaughter
Rhaena, who has been living on Dragonstone
with Rhaenyra and Daemon.
But Rhaenys is cold to Rhaenyra.
She’s always been a bit hostile to Rhaenyra,
maybe envious that Rhaenyra is heir to the
Throne when Rhaenys herself was rejected from
the Throne.
But now Rhaenys is really mad because she
believes that Rhaenyra killed her son Laenor
– and apparently Rhaenyra has just let Rhaenys
believe that for the last six years.
Rhaenys wears black clothes, as though she’s
still mourning the deaths of her children.
Rhaenyra now says that she didn’t kill Laenor,
but she doesn’t reveal that Laenor is in
fact still alive in the east somewhere.
She wants to respect Laenor’s choice to
be free and anonymous.
And Rhaenyra proposes an alliance.
If Rhaenys supports Luke’s claim to Driftmark,
then Luke will marry Rhaena, and Jace will
marry Baela.
So when Jace becomes King of Westeros, Baela
will be queen.
And when Luke becomes Lord of Driftmark, Rhaena
will be Lady of Driftmark.
This alliance would make Rhaenys’ granddaughters
two of the most powerful women in Westeros.
But Rhaenys has said before that she’s more
interested in keeping her family safe than
she wants political power.
If the Hightowers bring down Rhaenyra, Rhaenys
doesn’t want to go down with her.
So Rhaenys rejects Rhaenyra’s offer, and
says she’ll stand alone.
We hear thunder in the background, which evokes
the storm of war that’s coming.
And reminds us that Rhaenys’ mother was
Jocelyn Baratheon of Storm’s End, the castle
that withstands the storm.
So Rhaenyra feels alone and afraid.
Without allies, she can’t protect her family.
Rhaenyra visits Viserys, and asks him to defend
her.
Viserys had told Rhaenyra about the prophecy
of Aegon the Conqueror, that the Targaryens
must be united to save the world from the
white walkers.
But by making Rhaenyra his heir, then allowing
Alicent and Otto to take power, Viserys has
divided and weakened his family.
He’s failing as a king and as a father.
In the morning, we see how Viserys’ sickness
has ravaged his body.
We see the pain he’s in.
But today, Viserys refuses to drink the milk
of the poppy drug.
He wants his mind clear, so he can finally
fix the political divide in his family.
In the books, Viserys doesn’t have this
terrible leprosy disease.
Viserys just has a weak heart cause he’s
fat and drinks too much, and he cuts his hand
on the Iron Throne.
The books say that Viserys is just not that
interested in politics.
But in the show, Viserys has good intentions,
he does care, he just makes bad mistakes,
and eventually gets too sick and weak.
The author of the books George Martin says
that the Viserys in Hot D is a much better
and more tragic character than the Viserys
in the books – so much so that George feels
tempted to rewrite his books.
Otto holds court as Hand of the King to decide
who’ll inherit Driftmark after Corlys.
Of course, Otto has already agreed to give
Driftmark to Vaemond, so this is just empty
political theatre, a cloak of righteousness.
Vaemond speaks of the history of House Velaryon,
how they are one of the only surviving families
from Old Valyria, how they’ve been allies
of the Targaryens for centuries.
Vaemond says he has true Velaryon blood – implying
that Luke is a bastard, and not a real Velaryon.
Before Otto can give Driftmark to Vaemond,
King Viserys unexpectedly turns up.
He walks slowly and painfully to the Throne,
making this huge effort to support his daughter
Rhaenyra and her family.
Viserys’ brother Daemon helps him to his
throne and puts his crown back on his head
when it falls off.
It wasn’t in the script for Viserys’ crown
to fall off – that just happened accidentally,
and the actors went with it.
It’s a touching moment of love and support
between brothers with a rough history.
In Episode 1, it was hinted that Daemon might
kill Viserys to take his crown.
But even after all the fights and exiles,
Daemon is loyal to his brother.
Viserys says this whole Velaryon succession
question was already settled – Lord Corlys
wants Luke to inherit Driftmark.
And Rhaenys agrees.
Earlier, Rhaenys had said she wouldn’t support
Luke.
But now she does, and agrees to Rhaenyra’s
proposal to marry Luke to Rhaena and Jace
to Baela.
So Rhaena will be Lady of Driftmark, and Baela
will be Jace’s queen.
It’s a pretty good compromise, really – cause
Rhaena and Luke’s children will have Velaryon
blood through Rhaena’s mother Laena.
So if Vaemond really just cares about the
Velaryon bloodline, he should be okay with
Luke and Rhaena taking Driftmark.
But Vaemond wants the power for himself.
Viserys calls Vaemond a second son, which
reminds us that Vaemond may feel frustrated
that he’s always been less powerful than
his big brother Lord Corlys.
And Vaemond’s angry about the lies, that
everyone’s pretending that Luke is Laenor’s
son when he’s really Harwin’s bastard.
So Vaemond finally shouts the truth – that
Rhaenyra’s sons are “bastards” – and
he calls Rhaenyra a “whore”.
Vaemond knows that he’ll be punished for
this.
Vaemond’s actor says Vaemond falls on his
sword to tell the truth.
Suddenly, Daemon cuts through Vaemond’s
head.
The cut is so clean because Daemon uses his
Valyrian steel sword Dark Sister, and Valyrian
steel is super sharp.
In the books, Vaemond’s death is different.
Rhaenyra orders Daemon to kill Vaemond, and
then Rhaenyra feeds Vaemond’s corpse to
her dragon.
So Rhaenyra seems more villainous in the books
here.
Vaemond’s corpse is.. reassembled by the
silent sisters.
The silent sisters are an order of women in
the Faith of the Seven who prepare the dead
for the grave.
They wear grey, and swear vows of chastity
and silence.
They’re called “Death’s handmaidens”,
or “the Stranger’s wives” – cause
the Stranger is the god of death in the Faith.
The sisters cover their face because it’s
“ill fortune to look on the face of death”.
But Rhaenys watches as the sisters prepare
the corpse of her brother-in-law.
She says the Stranger has visited her more
times than she can count.
Her daughter Laena died, her son Laenor seemingly
died, her husband Corlys may soon die.
And if this conflict between Rhaenyra and
Alicent gets worse, many more people will
die.
By siding with Rhaenyra, Rhaenys has put herself
and her grandkids in danger.
The royal family have dinner, and the showrunners
took inspiration here from the Last Supper
painting by da Vinci.
Rhaenyra and Alicent sit apart from each other.
Which contrasts with how close they were in
the past.
This shot is based on an illustration in the
book Fire & Blood.
Viserys holds this dinner to try to reunite
his family before he dies.
In the throne room, Viserys used his strength
as king.
But now, Viserys shows his vulnerability as
a father and a husband.
He takes off his mask to show his withered
face, and urges his family to make peace for
his sake as a dying old man who loves them.
Rhaenyra is moved by her father’s words,
so Rhaenyra thanks Alicent for loving and
supporting Viserys all these years.
Alicent finds common ground with Rhaenyra,
and says Rhaenyra will be a good queen.
And that startles Otto, cause his whole plan
is to make Aegon king instead of Rhaenyra.
But Alicent and Rhaenyra really try to reconcile,
so for a moment it seems like peace is possible.
But Rhaenyra and Alicent’s children continue
their conflict.
Aegon insults Jace and his betrothed, Baela.
But Jace does the mature thing, and speaks
of friendship with Aegon and Aemond.
Helaena whispers another cryptic prediction.
She says “Beware the beast beneath the boards”.
This evokes dangerous hidden forces at the
Red Keep like Larys and Mysaria with their
spies and rats in the secret tunnels.
And metaphorically, the beast beneath the
boards could be the conflict and resentment
that still lurks beneath this appearance of
peace.
Helaena gives a speech about how her marriage
with Aegon isn’t so bad cause Aegon mostly
ignores her.
Which is dark, but it’s also the longest
coherent speech we’ve seen from Helaena,
and Otto is proud of his granddaughter.
Turns out even Otto is capable of being nice
sometimes.
Jace dances with Helaena, and their goofy
joy is about the most wholesome moment all
season.
Remember that Rhaenyra proposed for Jace to
marry Helaena.
So this is a bittersweet vision of what could
have been if that marriage happened.
Though at the same time, Jace dancing with
Helaena might be a subtle dig at Helaena’s
husband Aegon as revenge for Aegon insulting
Baela – that’s more how it seems in the
book, anyway.
But the adults get along, and have a good
time, and for a moment it seems like there
might be peace between Rhaenyra and Alicent’s
families.
So Viserys goes to bed believing that he’s
done the right thing, and everything’s gonna
be okay.
And then everything goes wrong.
A servant puts a roast pig in front of Aemond.
And Luke laughs.
Because previously, Luke gave Aemond a pig
to bully him.
And Luke is the one who cut out Aemond’s
eye last episode.
So Aemond is furious, and he gives a subtly
insulting speech.
He says Jace and Luke are “Strong boys”,
which sounds like a compliment, but really
he’s saying that they are Harwin Strong’s
bastard sons.
So the boys fight, until Daemon ends the scuffle
with one finger.
Daemon stares down Aemond, and he wins the
staring contest cause he has twice as many
eyes.
It looks these Aemond and Daemon would love
to fight, or make out, or something.
Aemond seems to both idolize Daemon and see
him as a rival.
When Daemon killed Vaemond, Aemond looked
inspired.
Rhaenyra and Alicent hold hands and try to
be friends again.
But these mothers have passed their conflict
down to their children, and the children have
not let go of this rivalry.
The book says that just “The sins of the
fathers” are visited on sons, and “the
sins of mothers” are as well.
Can Rhaenyra and Alicent undo the damage of
their past conflict?
We see Mysaria meet with Talya.
Mysaria was Daemon’s lover, and has now
become a spymaster.
Talya is Alicent’s maid in the Red Keep.
And now it seems that Talya is spying for
Mysaria.
So what is Mysaria up to?
Previously Mysaria spied for Otto.
Is Mysaria still working for Otto, or is she
maybe working for Larys now?
Are Mysaria’s child spies listening from
the secret passages in the Red Keep, and that’s
how Larys knows things?
Or is Mysaria working for herself?
Maybe she wants revenge on Daemon for him
abandoning her.
Is Mysaria the beast beneath the boards that
Helaena mentioned?
Viserys is dying.
He’s in pain, he’s heavily drugged.
So he speaks to Alicent, but Viserys thinks
he’s speaking to Rhaenyra.
He tries to continue his earlier conversation
with Rhaenyra about Aegon’s dream, the prophecy
that the Targaryens must unite to save Westeros.
Alicent doesn’t know about this prophecy.
But she hears Viserys say “Aegon” and
“You must do this”, so Alicent thinks
Viserys wants her to make their son Aegon
king.
That’s not what Viserys means – Viserys
barely remembers his son Aegon exists.
What Viserys actually means is that Rhaenyra
is the prince that was promised – that Rhaenyra
is the saviour who will unite the realm and
defeat the white walkers.
And we know that’s not true.
The white walkers don’t actually turn up
until a hundred and seventy years later in
Game of Thrones.
But this is a classic Targaryen mistake.
Several generations of Targaryens have believed
that they will be the heroes to save the world,
but been wrong.
Rhaegar Targaryen believes himself to the
prince that was promised, but then he changes
his mind and says his son is the saviour.
Aemon Targaryen on his deathbed says that
Daenerys is the prince that was promised.
Aegon the Conqueror, who started this prophecy,
thought that he would be the one to beat the
white walkers – at least according to the
showrunner of Hot D, that detail isn’t in
the books.
But this is one of the dangers of prophecy
– people assume that they or their children
are the most important people in the world,
at that can lead to disaster.
Alicent wrongly believes that Viserys’ dying
wish is for Aegon to be king – even though
Alicent just said she supports Rhaenyra, and
told Aegon that her not her son.
But maybe on some level Alicent wants to believe
this.
Because Alicent and Otto have spent years
building political strength for their family.
And Alicent’s resentment of Rhaenyra for
her lies and infidelity have not gone away.
So a dangerous mix of emotion ambition prophecy
and confusion is swirling through Alicent’s
mind.
When it’s time to decide who gets the Throne,
who will Alicent choose?
Alicent leaves, and the king dies alone.
Viserys says “No more”, and “My love”.
His love is Aemma, his first wife.
Viserys’ actor says Viserys never stops
loving Aemma, and sees Aemma’s face as he
dies.The phrase “No more” might refer
to Aemma saying she won’t birth any more
children.
Viserys’ insistence on impregnating Aemma
despite the health risks got Aemma killed,
and Viserys still feels guilty for that.
“No more” might also mean Viserys will
feel “No more” pain – he has suffered
so much, but now that he.. thinks that everything
will be fine, maybe Viserys welcomes death.
In a way, he’s been dead ever since Aemma
died.
This whole first season of House of the Dragon
has basically been just backstory.
This is the prologue, the setup, the building
of tension before the main event.
Now that King Viserys is dead, and now that
we know these characters and their relationships,
the real conflict can begin.
If you wanna know the full story of Hot D,
you’ve gotta check out the book, Fire & Blood.
There’s also the main series of Game of
Thrones books, and the worldbook, and Dunk
& Egg.
You can get any one of these on audiobook
for free right now at audible.com/asx.
Sign up for a Premium Plus trial membership,
and you get an audiobook to keep, even if
you cancel the trial.
You can get any Game of Thrones book, or Lord
of the Rings, or Dune.
Membership also includes unlimited access
to thousands of audiobooks and shows in the
Audible Plus Catalog.
Sign up at audible.com/asx, or text asx to
500-500.
Thanks for watching, please like and subscribe.
We’re doing a livestream each Sunday right
after Hot D episodes.
Then one of these Explained videos later in
the week.
Thank you to the Patrons, including hayden
ross, Evelyn Ng, Jake Relis, Jeff Tobin, Audun
Landøy Solli, Emma Stillman, and nicktelecast..
Cheers.